[Musique]
bonsoir à tous lundi 12 février
bienvenue pour une nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv 78è les
titres de ce set 8 journal séance du
conseil départemental vendredi dernier à
versailles les élus ont reçu le préfet
des yvelines pour un bilan des services
de l'état dans le département serge
morvan a été largement questionné sur la
ligne 18 dont le calendrier modifié doit
encore être dévoilés
reportage les yvelines touché en ce
début d'année par les intempéries en
première ligne les agriculteurs comment
ont-ils été touchées par les inondations
la neige et le gel nous poserons la
question à frédéric arnould président
des jeunes agriculteurs d'île de france
le syndicat se réunit ce vendredi à
rosny sur seine pour une assemblée
générale élective
et puis il s'agit de son 117e logement
dans les yvelines solidarités nouvelles
pour le logement a inauguré un studio à
voisins le bretonneux c'est une personne
en situation précaire qui va pouvoir en
bénéficier
le temps de retrouver une situation
stable et puis nous reviendrons
également dans ce journal sur la
rencontre entre patrons pme et
dirigeants du cac 40 ce samedi avec
nouveau deux invités deux présidents de
pme yvelinoise qui ont participé à ce
rendez vous c'est à suivre
c'est un exercice traditionnel devant le
conseil départemental le préfet des
yvelines a présenté vendredi le rapport
d'activité 2010 cette aide des services
de l'état sur le territoire serge mans
vend ensuite échanger avec les élus qui
ont pu lui poser leurs questions un
sujet est revenu sur la table la ligne
18 dépression avec ce sujet de nicolas
landry le calendrier des travaux de la
ligne 18 c'est l'objet de la question
posée au préfet par le conseiller
départemental
olivier de la fère et le représentant de
l'état dans les yvelines a rappelé les
concertations en cours sur ce dossier
ensuite bilan de concertation avant que
le gouvernement ait de nouveau
calendrier dans la présentation et rêver
je démens tout à l'heure enfin conseil
de surveillance la société immo paris en
mars
la meilleure façon de ne pas traiter un
problème c'est d'être on passe du groupe
de travail c'est ce qui se fait
aujourd'hui alors que les choses sont
claires
cette ligne 18 ans a besoin alors c'est
vrai qu'il ya 2024 légion mais il n'ya
pas que ça il ya pour aussi arriver à
trouver des solutions nouvelles de
transports pour les personnes qui
travaillent sur saint quentin
pierre bédier président du conseil
départemental est impliqué sur le
dossier
il a été reçu mardi 6 février au
ministère des transports on nous a
présenté trois calendriers différents
donc cet état c'est assez surprenant
le tracé semble confirmer le calendrier
les beaucoup moins et donc on aimerait
bien en savoir plus pierre bédier a
demandé qu'une étude soit faite pour
qu'on sache exactement les coûts et la
date d'activité de mise en activité de
du chantier c'est ça qui nous
interpellent et qui nous inquiète
une inquiétude due aux problématiques
autour du calendrier prévu pour 2024
l'ouverture de la ligne 18 sur la partie
yvelinoise pourrait finalement être
retardé un début d'année compliqué du
point de vue de la météo la région et le
département ont subi de plein fouet deux
événements climatiques inondations en
fin janvier et la semaine dernière vous
l'avez vu sur notre antenne des chutes
de neige puis du verglas vous avez sans
doute d'ailleurs eu encore quelques
difficultés ce matin paul verglas météo
capricieuse on pense forcément aux
agriculteurs comment les intempéries ont
un tel impact et ses agriculteurs on va
poser tout de suite la question à notre
invité frédéric arnaud bonsoir vous êtes
le président des jeunes agriculteurs
d'ile-de-france alors vous tenez ce
vendredi une assemblée générale élective
dans les yvelines où on va en parler
dans un instant déjà sur les intempéries
on peut on peut dire que ces nouvelles
souffrances vécues par par les
agriculteurs
oui alors je pense que si on veut faire
un point de comparaison par rapport à
l'année 2016
d'ores et déjà on peut déjà dire que ça
arrive plus tôt dans la saison donc il
ya moins de charge d'engager donc
économiquement c'est quand même un peu
moins impactants 2016 c'était arrivé oui
rendement divisé par deux pour les
céréaliers perte totale pour les
maraîchers pertes au total pour les
éleveurs donc c'est quand même beaucoup
plus impactant cependant faut quand même
savoir que là ça arrive à une période où
il ya quand même des cultures qui sont
en place donc sur les céréales notamment
en blé en colza il y aura des pertes
significatives en maraîchage y avait
aussi des cultures qui étaient implantés
donc sur ces cultures là il y aura aussi
des pertes et à ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que il ya aussi le revers de la
médaille c'est que on aura aussi des
cultures implantées là février mars à
nous et il ya des parcelles où il y
avait un mètre cinquante d'eau autant
vous dire que ça va être compliqué de
remettre du matériel dans ces personnes
lancé par certaines banques des récoltes
complètement noyé sur certains endroits
ah ben il ya des parts des chants qui
ont été complètement complètement noyés
et eau sur lequel il y aura on prend à
rien récolté quoi et ça sera peut-être
difficile de réimplanter quelque chose
alors dans cet épisode des inondations
il ya une polémique qui a été lancé par
brasilia blow l adjointe à
l'environnement à la mairie de paris
elle a affirmé que les agriculteurs
étaient en partie responsables de la
force de ces inondations pour l
agriculture intensive la disparition
aussi des réduisent la capacité
d'absorption des terres quelle a été
votre réaction le fait de mettre
finalement la responsabilité sur le dos
des agriculteurs
il ya deux choses la première chose
c'est que tous les experts s'accordent à
dire que les terres agricoles sont
incapables de de supporter 250 mm d'eau
en deux mois et les un filtre un filtre
est comme ça c'est tous les experts
s'accordent à le dire la deuxième chose
c'est que même lot elle habite quand
même en ville elle s'est quand même que
l'urbanisation et la bétonisation des
sols et l'artificialisation des sols
ça aide quand même pas ça va être quand
même pas à faire évacuer l'eau
sans parler des zones inondables qui
sont aujourd'hui construites et qu'on
continue à construire sans jamais se
remettre en question donc je pense que
avant de remettre en cause l'agriculture
elle ferait mieux de déjà de se remettre
en question sur ses envies
d'urbanisation autour de paris quoi
alors après les inondations deuxième
souci climatique et la semaine dernière
l'épisode de neige et de gel sur le
département
est-ce qu'il ya là pour le coup va y
avoir une incidence sur les récoltes ou
l'épisode n'a pas été assez bon
finalement mal ah bon c'est un peu tôt
pour le dire oui je pense que en
arboriculture il y aura quand même des
choses à surveiller parce que on a eu
quand même jusqu'à présent un temps
assez doux assez chaud et est du coup
les végétations et notamment les les les
arbres étaient quand même plutôt un
stade avancé donc faudra voir quand même
les impacts du gel sur le reste je pense
que le fait d'avoir eu entre 15 et 20
centimètres de neige avant ça a permis
de passer
ce cet épisode de geler parce que la
neige fait office de manteau protecteur
d'accord pour les cultures donc c'est
quand même un mal pour un bien
mais voilà il est trop tôt pour tirer
les conclusions mais c'est sûr qu'on
sera vigilant à aux conséquences que ça
aura alors à quelques jours de
l'ouverture du salon de l'agriculture
les jeunes agriculteurs d'île de france
je vous représentez se réunissent en
assemblée générale élective c'est dans
les yvelines et ça sera ce vendredi à
rosny-sur-seine l'occasion a notamment
de réduire les les instances du syndicat
au niveau régional vous avez été élu il
ya deux ans à la tête donc des jeunes
agriculteurs d'île de france étaient à
etréchy en essonne est ce que ce
vendredi où serait candidat pour un
deuxième mandat
écoutez je pense que oui je serai
candidat après le résultat je suis un
peu je le connais vrai que vendredi
non je pense que c'est important quand
on est quand on est jeune on apprend en
fait il ya deux ans quand je suis arrivé
je ne maîtrisez pas du tout les sujets
je débutais un petit peu et je pense
qu'au bout de deux ans et là on commence
à être un peu efficace c'est un peu
dommage de partir au bout de deux ans
voilà je trouve que je trouve que ça a
du sens de rester et pigeons avec deux
ans de recul maintenant je vois
exactement quelles sont les priorités et
quelles sont les choses sur lequel on
doit faire avant on doit avancer
et oui en effet c'est ça ça s'inscrit
dans une continuité mais justement si on
revient deux ans en arrière 3 capes que
vous étiez fixé à l'époque installations
environnement est aussi communication
positif c'était les 3/4 de l'époque deux
ans après cette élection quel bilan vous
pouvez dresser si on y apprend les
nations si si on prend je pense qu'on a
quand même réussi à faire avant
certaines sources avaient avancé
certaines choses m'ont la communication
on a créé une marque s'appelle le bon
sens paysan qu'on peut retrouver sur
twitter et sur facebook toutes les deux
semaines il ya quand même un visuel qui
sort qui permet de mettre en avant le
travail des agriculteurs au moment où
par elle la publication donc c'est
important de communiquer sur notre
métier et que les gens sachent bien ce
qu'on fait au moment à un moment donné
voilà plutôt que de se poser des
questions et d'avoir de mauvaises
réponses
au moins ça permet de d'éclaircir des
fois certaines questions
en termes de en termes d'installation on
n'a pas mal fait évoluer les choses en
effet pendant ces deux ans c'est pas mal
on s'est beaucoup appuyé sur le fait de
d'essayer de faire en sorte que nos
jeunes puissent s'installer dans une
meilleure condition
donc on a travaillé avec l'ensemble de
nos partenaires que ce soit les banques
les assurances les coopératives la
chambre d'agriculture le conseil
régional l'état voilà on essayé de
réunir tous les partenaires pour essayer
de mettre en place de nouvelles de
nouveaux dispositifs qui permettent à
nos jeunes de s'installer dans de bonnes
conditions
et puis ça sera aussi le la continuité
c'est de maintenant travailler sur la
résilience de deux de ses porteurs de
projets et faire en sorte qu'ils soient
les mieux protégés possible et le plus
les plus que ça de plus en plus capables
a passé les aléas qu'ils soient
climatiques économiques
voilà où climatique et puis on a aussi
mis en place un nouveau dispositif à
l'installation qui a permis aux jeunes
de 20 qui redonne envie aux jeunes de
passer par le parcours et d donc vous
savez que les jeunes ont des aides à
l'installation et aujourd'hui on a on a
un nouveau dispositif qui leur permet de
presque toucher le double 2 du montant
donc en gros pour être transparents sans
on passe de 15000 à presque trente mille
euros de aux aides de trésorerie au
démarrage ce qui est quand même non
négligeable un mot rapide très très
rapidement sur le thème de cet âge et ça
sera à quel avenir pour l'agriculture à
l'échelle de l'europe on imagine
thématique importante en ce moment même
où a été ratifié récemment le traité du
c'est un traité de libre-échange entre
l'ue et le canada et qui suscite
beaucoup d'inquiétude chez les
agriculteurs n'ont pas les agriculteurs
on s'est toujours vus comme des
européens convaincus
donc oui on
on croit en l'europe on croit en
l'avenir et on croit en ce qu'elle peut
nous apporter
seulement cela qu'aujourd'hui on a quand
même beaucoup de questionnements on
aimerait bien savoir où est ce qu'on va
on voit bien qu'il ya des grosses
distorsion de concurrence au sein de
l'union européenne
et l'idée de cette table ronde où on
invite notamment jacques delahaye qui
est députée européenne ee et christophe
hillairet qui est président de la
chambre de région ile de france mais qui
est aussi membre du copa cogeca à
bruxelles
l'idée c'est qu'on puisse vraiment
éclaircir ces points d'interrogation
pour qu'on puisse avancer un peu plus
sereinement dans l'avenir merci à
frédéric arnould d'avoir été avec nous
le rappelle que vous êtes le président
des jeunes agriculteurs d'ile-de-france
et pour plus d'informations sur ce
syndicat agricole vous pouvez vous
rendre sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran rendre le
logement plus accessibles aux personnes
en situation précaire c'est le mot
d'ordre de solidarité nouvelles pour le
logement
cette association oeuvre depuis 25 ans
pour permettre aux plus fragiles de se
loger décemment
elle a inauguré vendredi dernier un
nouveau studio à voisins le bretonneux
camille lambert était sur place
32 m² coin cuisine salle de bains et vue
sur cour ce sera le nouveau logement
d'une personne en situation précaire il
a rejoint la flotte de l'association
solidarités nouvelles pour le logement
et les personnes les personnes qui
viennent dans les logements et félins
ont des profils extrêmement différents
ça peut être des personnes qui viennent
de la rue ça peut être des personnes qui
dorment dans leur voiture
les personnes en situation de
suroccupation dans un logement au total
tout compris on en est à peu près à 300
euros de loyer par mois
objectif loués à des personnes en
difficulté le temps qu'elle retrouve une
situation stable ce logement et le 117e
dans les yvelines est saine elle
acquiert et rénove les futures
habitations
depuis 1997 elle est venue en aide à
près de 500 familles dans le département
nous leur donnons un tremplin pour
rebondir dans la vie les personnes les
familles il reste environ deux ans et
demi ou trois ans avec nous pour se
ressourcer pour repartir avoir un
logement se projeter tant qu'on n'a pas
de logement ou kobe dans des conditions
de surpeuplement
ce n'est pas possible pour obtenir ce
nouveau studio à voisins le bretonneux
160000 euros ont été nécessaires pour
l'achat et la rénovation
un financement partagé avec la ville
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines l'état et la fondation abbé
pierre dix neuf nouveaux projets sont en
cours notamment à viroflay et amène à
des logements solidaires également
inauguré en fin de semaine dernière à
guyancourt c'est la résidence sociale la
minière dans le quartier du pont du
rotois re géré par adoma l'ensemble
compte 192 studios meublés et des
solutions temporaires pour des
travailleurs masculins des retraités ou
encore des familles monoparentales et
des goûts des couples sans enfant les
résidences s'acquittent chaque mois d'un
reste à payer adaptés à leurs ressources
et situation familiale
objectif à terme retourner dans le parc
immobilier traditionnel
propos recueillis par marylène yapi chez
nous ce qui était important survient en
course et que chacun puisse
effectivement se loger quelque soit
a sion et c'est très gênant c'est le
permis de répondre à des familles pour
des familles à loger des familles qui
sont à des moments d'un parcours de vie
qui sont un petit peu accidentelle qui
leur permet de
nathan convergent de trouver un logement
et de pouvoir après effectivement
rebondir pendant ce temps sur cette
résidence ça leur permet avec des
travailleurs sociaux de pouvoir monter
des dossiers voir effectivement après
avoir un logement pérenne et pouvoir les
aider aussi dans des démarches
administratives ou pourvoi des retours à
l'emploi à des patrons de pme des
dirigeants du cac 40 pour un grand tête
à tête pour la croissance le top c'est
le nom de cette rencontre qui s'est
tenue ce samedi au conseil économique
social et environnemental à paris
organisé par l'afep c'est l'association
et qui regroupe 120 des plus grandes
entreprises françaises des speed dating
de dix minutes pour faire du business et
aussi avec l'aîné quelques conseils avec
moi sur ce plateau de participants à cet
événement en thierry godin bonsoir qui
soit avec le président de france terre
nique une société basée à montigny le
bretonneux et fabre et fabrice à
provenaient également avec mon plateau
soit président de cette way est une
société de services en ingénierie qui
est basé à versailles
on va commencer par un petit tour de
table justement un petit mot sur votre
activité
on fait de la prestation pour les
industriels principalement dans
l'automobile et l'aéronautique on est
basé en ile de france avec des activités
aussi dans le sud ouest et dans l'ouest
de la france
thierry godin france thermique fabrique
conçoit et installe des équipements de
combustion oui donc des brûlures
industriels qui sont utilisés en
chauffage urbain incinération des
ordures ménagères et dans l'industrie
lourde pour fournir en souvent la vapeur
sur sur les usines nous avaient tous
deux participé je les ira cet événement
top c'était donc samedi le top
thierry godin pardon comment vous avez
déjà entendu parler de cet événement et
pourquoi avoir voulu y participer alors
tout simplement par les réseaux sociaux
oui notre époque
et pourquoi voir leurs avoir voulu y
participer parce que d'abord la moitié
de nos clients étaient présents côté
grandes entreprises que toutes ces
clients ont réussi plus longtemps leur
internationalisation et que notre enjeu
principal est de réussir la nôtre donc
j'étais venu glaner des conseils et
votre côté nous on est on a pu se
présenter grâce à notre banc
conçue depuis des années qu à la société
générale adrien des sponsors de cette
manifestation et nous c'était pour
développer dans d'autres secteurs des
économies qu'on est très présent dans
l'aéronautique et l'automobile et on
voulait aller vers un secteur de de
l'énergie et du recyclage
alors c'est une participation qui s'est
faite sur ces élections vous étiez plus
de 400 patrons présents samedi
j'ai dû faire acte de candidature c'est
ça pour y participer alors en fait on a
rempli sur un site internet des
descriptifs et on a fait des choix des
choix par rapport aux sociétés qui était
présente et on avait quatre choix à
faire justement quels choix du côté de
france ternie quel choix vous avez fait
voilà quel patron quel dirigeant avait
voulu rencontrer je privilégie l
industrie parce qu'on nous en client
l'industrie et les services collectifs
et dans l'industrie donc j'ai choisi
saint gobain arkema imerys et suggère
donc c'était des entretiens à chaque
fois des speed dating on peut dire de
dix minutes c'est sa 7 7 à 10 minutes
est minutes 7 minutes très précisément
quelles questions vous avez pu leur
poser pas ses dirigeants bien de savoir
comment est ce qu'il pouvait nous aider
à exister commercialement à l'export
donc à créer une image a donné confiance
dans la société
fabrice robert vous tel quel patron
avait voulu vais vous voulu rencontrer
quelques questions alors deux axes
primordiaux et scène les entreprises aux
services numériques avec capgemini parce
qu'on voit aussi se développer dans ces
domaines là et après comme je vous ai
dans l'environnement avec veolia et suez
voilà nous c'était effectivement un peu
différent c'est comment développer à
mener notre nos spécialités qui sont
plutôt automobiles et aéronautiques dont
92 de l'énergie et voir si techniquement
il ya des passerelles possibles et
devenir comme nous on est des
prestataires enfin des sociétés
fournisseurs importants au niveau de ces
domaines là est-ce que vous avez obtenu
toutes les réponses tous les conseils
que vous aviez recherché on a déjà pu
rentrer en contact avec du top
management et le top management de ces
entreprises là après il ya des échanges
de cartes des pointeurs qui ont été
commis tôt identifié et peut-être des
intérêts communs ce qui est le principe
même du business
cyril gollain vous de votre côté vous
avez pu obtenir des réponses les
conseils aussi donc les foucades et des
pistes qui j'espère vont déboucher met
par exemple en trouver des agents en
russie en chine nous accompagner dans
les filiales du groupe qui sont
présentes à l'étranger etc
une dernière question pour refermer cet
entretien un petit tour de table
comment voilà quels bénéfices a pu
apporter ça pue à vous apporter cette
cette rencontre et voilà de quelle
manière vous en êtes sortis grandis
thierry godin c'est une question
difficile mais qui mérite d'être posée
oui donc je pense qu'en fait c'est
l'occasion de rencontrer des gens de
niveau qu'on ne rencontrerait pas oui et
donc d'avoir une représentation concrète
du management de ces entreprises et pour
sannois alors moi je crois plus à la
gravité que la capillarité
et donc c'est à dire eh ben c'est à dire
que s'adressait à s'adresser à dieu qu'à
ses saints et là on a eu l'occasion en
fait d'eux de se présenter et de montrer
ce qu'on était capable de faire
voilà alors j'espère que ça débouchera
sur du business derrière on verra bien
après la fait pas parler de renouveler
ce genre d'expérience vous pourriez
participer de nos banquiers oui ça me
semble indispensable
merci à vous d'être témoigner de cette
expérience sur ce plateau dir écho d'un
jeu rappelle président de france terre
nitya montigny le bretonneux et fabrice
provenait la présidente de cette fois
une société qui est basée à versailles
merci c'était samedi également le cfi de
montigny le bretonneux a ouvert ses
portes au public c'est affi pour écoles
connecté au futur de l'industrie cette
journée était l'occasion d'en apprendre
plus sur la robotique
le génie informatique ou encore la
domotique des formations qui sont
accessibles à des après le bac
reportage d'aurélie rond et nicolas
landry maintenant je vais alimenter le
ventilateur donc qui va servir pour la
climatisation
jean est en licence coordinateur de
projet et objets connectés au sefi de
montigny le bretonneux
après un bts électronique il a choisi de
suivre cette nouvelle formation proposée
par l'école connecté au futur de
l'industrie
son objectif monter sa propre entreprise
dans quelques années on apprend que la
coordination
donc le schiste ont des équipes savoir
faire des réunions savoir fixer des
objectifs répondre à des appels d'offres
savoir négocier en plus de formations en
lien avec la domotique le ca fille de
montigny le bretonneux permet de se
former en électronique et robotique mais
aussi en réseau et génie informatique
cette école de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie d'île de france accueille
350 jeunes apprentis toutes les
formations sont en alternance pour les
cycles de bts nous avons effectivement
une alternance d'une semaine une semaine
une semaine entreprises une semaine au
cfa sur les cycles de l'école qui vont
pas deux qui vont de bac +2 à bac +5
l'alternance est différente puisque les
jeunes ont besoin d'avoir plus de temps
ou au cfa ou à l'entreprise pour pouvoir
développer des projets donc là
effectivement l'alternance peut aller
deux mois deux mois trois mois trois
mois quatre mois c'est un mois mais le
changer l'installation la nouvelle
technologie
je trouverais c'était c'était pas mal et
puis je ne contrôlais sa maison à
distance pour enfin où son bâtiment du
coup se veut beaucoup plus des métiers
d'avenir qui offre de nombreux débouchés
80% des jeunes trouvent un emploi dans
les six mois après l'obtention de leur
diplôme
un mot de sport et du cyclisme on le
pensait à la retraite à 106 ans robert
marchand était de retour ce dimanche sur
la piste du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines un peu plus
d'un an après son record de l'heure il a
réalisé hier 16 tours pour une distance
totale de 4000 m robert marchand devait
en réaliser et 10 initialement on écoute
la réaction de ce sportif pas comme les
autres au micro de nicolas landry et
vous êtes content de revenir ici mais
entendu je suis incroyable c'est un pont
royal
j'ai déjà vu j'avais peur mais
g handball le choc de la 12e journée de
nationale 3 plaisir deuxième se
déplaçait sur le parquet du troisième
massy et keeper réserve de la formation
qui évolue en starlix et plus haut
niveau français
le match s'est terminé par une victoire
des estoniens dans les dernières
secondes score final 28 à 27
résumé de la rencontre avec michael et
demi d'euros et nicolas dans le web lui
défaite rageante pour les jaune et noir
de plaisir après avoir mené pendant une
grande partie du match à l'extérieur les
ivy loix 2e de national troyes n'ont pas
réussi à conserver leur avantage et
s'incline contre leurs poursuivantes les
seconds massy score final 28 à 27 ans
seulement dessus parce que je pense
qu'on avait toutes les armes pour pour
gagner le match
lugo utilisons ils n'ont pas paniqué
quand j'étais à moins 4 ils sont revenus
petit à petit au score et à
et nous on a acheté des ballons un peu
trop bêtement là où on aura dû attendre
un peu plus travailler un peu plus
autour de leur défense
on fait une entame de match
irréprochable et derrière on donne
beaucoup beaucoup trop de ballons à
l'adversaire
un retournement de situation orchestrée
par le gardien de massy justin porte à
l'homme clé de cette rencontre a mis en
échec les plaisirs ou en réalisant une
quinzaine d'arrêt pendant la partie au
fait c'était de sa partie est
j'irai pas dans le registre de dire que
le gardien n'est pas bon bien au
contraire
maintenant
faut être parfois capable de savoir lire
les modes de jeu des joueurs adverses et
dans ce registre là on a été très
mauvais on attirait toujours dans le
même mode de jeu et le gardien a fait
toutes ses parades dans les mêmes
intentions donc voilà c'est assez
frustrant
au classement ce résultat permet à massy
de revenir à hauteur des plaisirs ou à
la deuxième place du championnat avec 28
points chacun une défaite qui pourrait
remettre en cause les espoirs de montée
du promu yves binois maintenant on a
attendu moi je pense qu'on était un peu
la surprise du dvd match aller de phase
aller et je pense que c'est pas trop
bien aussi que moi si nous aligner
quelques quelques bons joueurs
ce que voilà maintenant il n'y a plus
l'effet de surprise donc on va être
attendu un peu partout et à nous de
faire en sorte d'élever notre niveau de
jeu
les plaisirs roy devront élever leur
niveau de jeu dès leur prochain match
ils recevront le dimanche 4 mars le
leader saint polois cette fois-ci
défaite interdite pour ce choc avant de
conclure ce journal c'était la quatrième
édition ce samedi le salon à des métiers
d'art de rambouillet se tenait donc
samedi je lis t-il événement à vocation
caritative est organisée chaque année
par le rotary club de la ville une
quarantaine d'exposants présents retour
sur cet événement avec nicolas landry et
mélanie poker le thuel simpson participe
pour la seconde fois au salon des
métiers d'art de rambouillet s'est uni
monteyne s'est lancée dans la peinture
sur porcelaine depuis deux ans j'ai une
clientèle qu'il commence à se faire en
fait ça fait deux ans que je suis
installé en tant que peintre sur
porcelaine et je recherche vraiment des
vrais salon des métiers d'art qui
correspondent en fait à mon activité
ce week-end s'étaient donné rendez-vous
tourneur sur bois verrier ou encore
couturier les intempéries de la semaine
dernière n'ont pas refroidi les
visiteurs la qualité des artisans est
absolument impressionnante enfin ils
sont a priori ce que je vois c'est
vraiment très très joli très bien fait
très très très beau donc je pense qu'on
revienne
on est venu ce matin par curiosité par
pure curiosité donc pour voir un peu ce
qui pouvait se faire en terme
d'innovation sur les différentes
matières ce salon a aussi un but
caritatif tous les bénéfices sont
reversés à l'association l'étoile de
martin
la première casquette c'est de financer
le matériel pour la recherche des
enfants qui sont atteints du cancer et
là sa deuxième casquette c'est de leur
permettent quand ils sont à l'hôpital de
passer le temps plus rapidement en
prenant des prêts si j tateurs en
prenant des clowns pour cette quatrième
édition le salon a réuni une quarantaine
d'exposants
c'est la fin de ce journal très bonne
soirée et excellente semaine à tous sur
tv 78
[Musique]